♪♪
Hey, good evening, and welcome to the table.
My name is Karen Minor, and we are live.
It is Sunday, July 12th, and what are we,
in month four of the pandemic?
And the reason for that is, you know,
if you see my roots and my gray hairs,
it's like the rings on a tree.
I can count the time.
It's been four months.
I'm so glad that you joined us tonight.
You are welcome here.
If you've been with the tables at the beginning,
or you're relatively new, or you're new tonight,
and just checking us out, I'm so glad that you've
chosen to be with us, and this is not an exclusive
opportunity or a club.
Our vision for the table is that it really is
communal, inclusive.
All are welcome.
So settle in.
If you'd like, comment down below.
Let us know that you're here.
Let us know where you're watching from.
We want to be able to welcome you personally.
And you are in for a really, really special night tonight.
Between the music and the message,
it's going to be really, really incredible.
So you picked a great night to be here.
And you can also share it later,
because it's caught on video,
and it will be available to watch and to share
after we're done going live tonight.
So feel free to do that.
I just have a couple of announcements
and ways to get connected here at the table.
They are both about our meetups,
which are our small groups.
The first one is our book club,
which meets monthly.
It's going to be meeting next Saturday,
July 18th at 10 a.m.
via Google Meets
to discuss this month's book selection.
Let me make sure I get it right.
It's called Dante and Aristotle Discover
the Secrets of the Universe.
And it sounds really, really good.
It's by Benjamin Sims.
Our meetup is facilitated by Sarah Johns
and Glenda Bayron.
And they would love it
if you could join them to discuss the book.
And even if you haven't read it,
I'm notorious for not reading the books
or maybe not quite getting done with the books,
but I still show up because I love
listening to the discussion.
I like the chat time with everybody.
And it's just really fun.
So you are more than welcome
to join us for that.
And if you'd like more information
on how to connect via Google Meets,
you can email Sarah,
S-A-R-A,
at thetabletx.org.
The second meetup
is for our teenagers.
Whether you call
the table home or not,
this group is open to you.
It's open to all teenagers.
And it's going to be a four-week study
to discuss race.
And it's going to be facilitated
by Maggie Tilford.
And it's going to start this coming Wednesday evening
and go each Wednesday
for four consecutive weeks.
So you'll be done before school starts
or who knows what's happening with school,
but it'll be done
before the proposed school start
in the middle of August.
And it's an open group
for any teens who might be wanting
or needing a space
to discuss race.
Talk a little bit about our country's history,
how we got to this current moment
in our society.
So all teens are welcome to that.
If you would like more information,
you can contact Maggie
at M-A-G-G-I-E
at thetabletx.org.
As we transition to worship,
I just wanted to share something
that I've been thinking about
lately and actually journaled about
recently.
It was inspired by
the passage in Joshua 2415
that says
choose this day
whom you will serve.
And the reason why this
scripture stuck out to me
at this moment in time
is that I found myself
with just
the not knowing about how
things are going to go,
the uncertainty,
all of the what-ifs.
I found myself
either throughout the day or when I wake up
in the morning with my jaw clenched,
my hands in fists,
breathing very shallow,
and just
finding myself a little stressed out
and realizing that
I can allow myself to go into
worry mode and what-ifs
scenario mode really, really
quickly.
The passage
choose this day whom you will serve
just challenged me
and I realized I've been
choosing stress and
choosing to live there
versus choosing just
handing it over to God and not that the
circumstances go away but it certainly
puts me in a healthier place
to process through and to make
decisions and to respond versus
react. So I'd like to
read what I wrote in my journal
and then after
that we're going to transition to
a wonderful song
led by Carter Livingston
assisted by his son Preston, which you're
really going to like.
Choose this day
whom you will serve.
God, I choose you.
I will continue to choose you
when fear, anxiety
and worry try to take over.
I will breathe you in
when my mind starts entertaining
what-ifs scenarios.
I will pray when my mind
and heart are unsettled.
I will give you my raw
honest, unedited
feelings in exchange for
your peace that surpasses
my own understanding.
I will choose to breathe in
your spirit when I am overwhelmed.
I will be reminded
of your goodness, faithfulness
and wonder
when I pause to soak in
a beautiful sunset or
contemplate the sure and steady growth
of an oak tree as it weathers
harsh seasons.
I will choose the way of
love, compassion
and perseverance.
I will choose you when this
gets difficult.
God, I will continue
to choose you.
Amen.
One day there'll be
no more waiting
left for our souls.
One day there'll be
no more children
longing for home.
One day when
the kingdom comes
right here where we stand
we'll see the
promised land.
Yeah, yeah.
One day
there'll be
Yeah, yeah.
One day
there'll be no more lives
taken too soon.
One day
there'll be no more need for
a hospital room.
One day every
tear that falls will be wiped
by His hand. We'll see
the promised land.
Yeah.
Hallelujah.
There will
be healing
from this heartbreak
we've been
feeling.
We'll sing in the darkest of
night cause we know
the light will come and there will
be healing.
Hallelujah.
One day
there'll be no more anger
left in our eyes.
One day the color
of our skin won't cause
a divide.
One day we'll be
family standing hand
in hand. We'll see
the promised land.
We'll see the promised
land. Hallelujah.
There will
be healing
from this heartbreak
we've been
feeling. We'll sing
in the darkest of night
cause we know the light will
come and there will be
healing.
Hallelujah.
Yeah.
One day every knee will
bow. Every tongue will
confess.
One day when our tired
bones find the rest.
One day
when the power of evil's
brought to an end.
We'll see the promised land.
See the promised
land. Hallelujah.
There
will be healing
from this heartbreak
we've been
feeling.
We'll sing in the dark
of night cause we know the
light will come and there will
be healing.
Hallelujah.
There will be healing.
There
will be healing.
Hallelujah.
Wow. Thank you Carter and Preston.
That was beautiful.
Man I really miss
playing together
with you Carter and
Wow. Got a little emotional there for a second.
And the rest of the band and just being
together with
this table community and
the energy that we can bring in a room
and you know doing
church this way is
not ideal obviously
but it is what
we got and so let's make the most of it
and this song
I'm about to play is called The Father's House
and so even though we're not together
physically
let's enter into the father's
house you know
and just set aside
everything that's been going on in our lives
and just tune in
to each other
even though we're not together
into our community
so I hope you
enjoy the song and
here we go.
Sometimes on this journey
I get lost in my mistakes
What looks to me like weakness
is a canvas for your strength
My story isn't over
My story's just begun
Failure won't define me
That's what my father does
Lay your burdens down
Here in the father's house
Check your shame at the door
Cause it ain't welcome anymore
You're in the father's house
Arrival's not the end game
The journey's where you are
You never wanted perfect
You just wanted my heart
If the story isn't over
If the story isn't good
Failure's never final
When the father's in the room
I say
Failure's never final
When the father's in the room
I say
Failure's never final
When the father's in the room
Lay your burdens down
Here in the father's house
Check your shame at the door
Cause it ain't welcome anymore
You're in the father's house
Compatibles come home
Help us find hope
Love is on the move
When the father's in the room
Frozen doors think wide
Dead come to life
Love is on the move
When the father's in the room
Miracles take place
A sinner could find faith
Love is breaking through
When the father's in the room
Jericho walls are quaking
Strongholds now are shaking
Love is breaking through
When the father's in the room
Lay your burdens down
Here in the father's house
Check your shame at the door
Cause it ain't welcome anymore
You're in the father's house
You're in the father's arms
Thanks Gary
So grateful for all the people
To contribute to
Times where you
Can be creative with music
And worship even in this format
So thank you guys so much for being a part of it
Um
This week has been kind of a heavy one for me
And I don't know about you
But anytime that I feel
Um
Kind of emotionally spent or exhausted
Uh
It's easy to
To kind of put up some walls
And um
So the song that I'm going to do
Um
Is called
I'm sorry
But I'm so sorry
For all these people
That I've lost
You're in the father's house
You're in the father's arms
And have already been made perfect
But I press on to take hold
Of that for which Christ
Jesus took hold of me
And I'm just so
Brateful that
Jesus takes hold of us
Even when we don't
Have it all together
When we screw it up
or our face with our
Weaknesses or
Up against our growth edges
Still I find that
He is taking hold of us
And He is offering love and compassion
And redemption and forgiveness
And
Yeah I just want to stay open
To those things as He offers them to me
Instead of closing off and
Escaping to my vices
Or maybe ignoring and just
You know
Binge watching or
Trying to escape
Some of the emotional feelings
That I need to process sometimes
I'm just grateful
That I find Him there still holding on to me
And encouraging me
To let Him in and to take down
Those walls and
To experience love, forgiveness
Hope
So I hope that you guys can hold on to that as well
This week
Come tear down
The walls I've built up
Every wall
I've built up
Every wall I've built up
Cause you
Deserve every piece
Of my heart
Every piece of my heart
Every piece
Of my heart
Come tear
Down the walls I've built up
Every wall
I've built up
Every wall I've built up
Cause you
Deserve every piece
Of my heart
Every piece of my heart
Every piece
Of my heart
And Lord
I am trusting
That you are a faithful
Father
And all that you
Have it is good
You're a
Generous giver
With love like no other
Won't you come
And break through to me
Come
Tear down the walls I've built up
Every wall
I've built up
Every wall I've built up
Cause you
Deserve every piece
Of my heart
Every piece of my heart
Every piece
Of my heart
And Lord
I am trusting
That you are a faithful
Father
And all that you have
It is good
You're a generous
Giver
With love like no other
So come and break
Through to me
Over and over
And over again
I am bringing
My heart to you
With open hands
Closer
And closer
You're drawing me in
As the depths of my heart
Lay before you
Again
Over and over
And over again
I am bringing
My heart to you
With open hands
Closer
And closer
You're drawing me in
As the depths of my heart
Lay before you
Again
So come
Tear down the walls I've built up
Every wall
I've built up
Every wall I've built up
Cause you
Deserve every piece
Of my heart
Every piece of my heart
Every piece
Of my heart
Come
Tear down the walls I've built up
Every wall
I've built up
Oh
Cause you
Deserve
Every piece of my heart
Every piece
Of my heart
Every piece of my heart
Over
And over
And over again
I'm bringing
My heart to you
With open hands
Closer
And closer
You're drawing me in
As the depths of my heart
Lay before you
Again
Over
And over
Lay it all down
You are good
Come
Tear down the walls I've built up
Every wall
I've built up
Jesus would you please
meet us
right where we're at
I know you're already there
but help us
to see you in our brokenness
just as much
as we see you in our victories
and our strengths
Thank you God that you have taken hold of us
long before we ever
took hold of you
We love you so much
Amen
Thanks Mindy
I just love how worship
and just taking time for a song
centers us
back on God
reminds us who he is, who we are
and that we're not alone
I appreciate that. Thank you Carter
and Preston and Gary and Mindy
Such a great collaboration tonight
The amazingness continues
I get the privilege
and the honor
to introduce our speaker
for tonight
Dawn
is a dear dear friend of mine
We met
I think it's been about three years ago
It was around 2017
I met Dawn
at a small group
that was led by
one of our
mutual friends, Lance Westbrook
and
man, I was just immediately
drawn to Dawn's warmth
his smile
He's just full of life
and he carries this light
inside of him that just, it feels like
a big hug every time you see him
and
after getting to know
him and hearing more of his story
I realized
that his
grace, his faith
his humility, his wisdom
were forged
during some challenging times
and just added
so much depth to who he is
and what he has to share
so I'm really really excited and
grateful that you all get to hear from him
as well
Not only is Dawn my friend
he's also one
of the members of our
table launch team, so he's been with us since the
beginning and even before that when we were
a part of New Hope Lucas
He's a small group
meetup leader at the table as well
He's an amazing dad
new dog owner
and just a wonderful human being
So it's, you know
usually I would say, you know, let's
welcome Dawn with some applause, but
I can't do that right now
so in lieu of applause, if you guys can
hit the love button or the
thumbs up button just to show
him some love right now and we'll give you some
virtual applause, Dawn
but we're just really really glad
that you're going to be speaking to us tonight
so take it away
Thank you, thank you, thank you
Karen, I appreciate that. That is a lot
actually to live up to
but I appreciate
that so very much
So, hi!
I am thrilled and excited
to be able to come and talk
to you guys in this manner
This was one of those
things that it's a little surreal
in some ways
and I am just super excited
just to be able, just to kind of share
something that's just, it's just important
to me. Our faith is just
what grounds us, it keeps us together
It encourages
us, it gives us
hope and
it's a sense of peace and comfort and I just
love talking about
our faith in general and so
I love being able to
just do that in this format
and so thank you
for this opportunity and everything
So I want to kind of go back a little
bit, so some of you guys have
heard a little bit of my story, I kind of
gave a little bit of my personal testimony
a few months ago at the table
when we were still meeting up face to
face and everything, but I want
to kind of dive a little bit into that
deeper
So one of the things I kind of
talked about then is that I grew up
very churched
in my life. I am one of those people
that I've always been in church
I don't know life
outside of the church very much
I have, my
grandfather's a preacher
we were at church every single Sunday
every single Sunday evening
Wednesday nights
if those of you who were ever
part of something called Awanas
I was a part of that program
growing up as a kid
I went to church camps
and then I
became a Christian
and I say that because
if you were like me, I said
that Lord's Prayer a hundred times
as a kid
because I wanted it to stick
So
I would
say that the last time I said
the Lord's Prayer to
accept Jesus into my heart
was when I was 16 years old
and then I was just like, okay, I'm done
saying that
and that was
interesting. It's been one of those things where
even when I was 16 years old
I was
just living in a place where
I
would go to church camp and I don't know if you guys
have ever experienced, but you go to these amazing
things and you have these gigantic
huge
mountain top experiences with God
and you come back to the normal
world and
things are just not the same
and so I wanted something
and I would kind of go back and forth
I would go spend a tremendous amount of time
with this very intense
Christian event
and I would come back to normal life
and things just wouldn't stick the same
so when I was
graduating high school I decided to go to a Bible college
and before you sit there
and say, whoa, and be super
impressed by that
I went to a Bible college
primarily because I was not trying to be a
pastor. That's not my calling
but I wanted to
just really learn and
understand and deepen my
relationship with God because again I wanted
it to stick. It was one of those things
I didn't want to do this whole waffling thing
in my life and stuff
and so
it's interesting because
here I'm 40 something years old
that's something I made a decision about 20
years ago and
there's a certain level of maturity
that comes with being
40 and looking back to when I
was a teenager
and thinking about my relationship with God
and it's something that
moves and breathes. That's something
that I didn't know at the time
it's like any
other real relationship in your life
it moves and changes and breathes
just as you mature
and grow up and get older
and situation changes and circumstances
changes so
yeah, I wanted to
share that with you so that you understand
a little bit of where I'm coming from
in terms of
being able to speak a little
bit because
it's just kind of like
Erin talked about, my journey has
taken me to some very interesting places
and the constant
thing through that, at least I hope, the constant
thing through that is my relationship
with God
and I don't say that to sound churchy
I know that we're in church but
I say that as a very sincere
thing because there's times where
I have a lot of doubts. I pick
up scripture and I would read it and I would get mad
or angry because of
not necessarily what the Bible was
saying but just how it was being used
I've had some very
challenging conversations with people in my life
challenging situations in my own heart
trying to
measure up
to certain things
and I want to kind of get into our
study a little bit tonight
so we are in the study of Luke
we are picking, we're going back
into that
that's where we're at
that Brett has kind of left us into
and when Brett
said, hey, would you like to
speak in front of the church? I was like
sure
and so he
gave me a lot of room to kind of go
and to look at the study
of Luke and I started going through
just reading certain sections throughout
looking at who Jesus
was and is and
everything and I was going through all the different stories
and there was one story that just really
connected
with me, I kept coming back to it
over and over and over again, I kept
reading it over and over again
it's probably something that's very familiar with you
all, I would assume that it
probably is, but we're
going to take a little bit of time and take
a look at this particular story
it's found in
it's Luke, from Luke chapter 7
it's
verse 36, so if you
have a Bible and you want to follow
along, you sure can and of course
everything's on the screen so we'll kind of
go through this
alright, so one of the Pharisees
asked Jesus to have dinner with him
so Jesus went to his
home and sat down to eat
with a certain unmoral woman
from a city
heard he was eating
there, so she brought a beautiful
alabaster jar filled with
expensive perfume
that she knelt behind him at his
feet, weeping
her tears fell
on his feet and she
wiped them off with her hair
then she kept kissing his feet
and putting the perfume on them
when the Pharisees who
invited him
saw this, he said
to himself
if this man were a prophet, he
would know what kind
of woman is
touching him
he's a sinner
oh heavens, he's a sinner
aren't we all sinners?
oh well
then Jesus answered
his thoughts
Simon, he said to the Pharisee, I have something
to say to you
go ahead teacher, Simon replied
then Jesus told him
a story, a man
loaned money to two people
5,000 pieces of silver
one to one
50 pieces to another
but neither of them could repay
for he kindly forgave
them both, cancelling their debts
who do you suppose
loved him more after that?
Simon
answered, I suppose the
one whom he cancelled the larger
debt, that's right
Jesus said, then he turned to the woman
and said to Simon, look
at this woman kneeling here
when I entered your home
she offered me water
to wash the dust off my feet
she washed them with her tears
and wiped them with her hair
you didn't greet me with a kiss
but from the time I first came in
she has not stopped kissing
my feet
you neglected the courtesy of olive oil
to anoint my head, but she has
anointed my feet
with a rare perfume
I tell you, her sins
and though there are many
they are forgiven
so she has shown me much love
but a person who is forgiven
little, shows only
little love
he said to the woman, your sins are forgiven
the men at the table
started talking
amongst themselves, who is this man
that goes around forgiving
sins, and Jesus said
to the woman, your faith has saved you
and go in peace
I kept going back
to this story over and over again
because
in many, many ways
again, those of you who are somewhat
familiar with my story
I feel like in many ways
I was very much like this
woman. I was
a sinner. I was the
I was seen as a
person from, because usually as
the story looks at, this is a
Pharisee, this is a
Jewish leader, this is a church leader
of the time. A person
who has a lot of prestige, has been
very educated, knows a lot of
things about scripture at the time
very well connected
probably nowadays has a huge
following on social media
if it was nowadays
and very influential
maybe has a megachurch if it was
around today. But
according to this Pharisee, this
person is a sinner
a horrible person
probably one
of the worst people that you could probably
imagine. And I'm trying not to say
anything specific because
honestly all of us can fit
into this category, quite frankly
at some point
in our lives we could all fit into this
category of
being that sinner
for me specifically
my biggest thing that
I was trying my best to hide
was the fact that I was gay
it was probably
the biggest sin
that I
wanted to hide
and I didn't want to share
I didn't want to share it with anybody
one of the things I did a lot when I was
growing up is that I
wrote in a lot of journals
I have journals from
college, from
early
on in my life, I've got
prayers in here, I've got
things I've
studied through scripture written out
in these journals, I've got
even just sometimes where I've just had a really bad day
and I just go in through and I
just needed to get it off my chest
but I've got a
ton of these journals from
way back when, and when
I go back and read some of this stuff
even to myself
I wouldn't even say the word
gay, I wouldn't even say the word
same-sex attracted, I always said
the word my struggle
that's always what was written
in my journal because I was
deathly afraid that if somebody found
my journal, they would pull it
out and they would use it
in some negative way against me
and they would make up all of these random things about my
life that weren't true
and
I felt like I had to keep
it a secret all the time
something
I had written not too long ago
probably a few years ago
late 30s
and everything like that
I just
I was trying to kind of come up with
this whole entire idea of my identity
because I know I'm a Christian
I can't separate that
I can't just wake up one day and be like
you know, I'm kind of done with the Bible
done with church
I don't want anything to do with that, that's not my life
that's just not
it has never been part of my life
it's very much ingrained
in who I am as a person
and how I live my life
so
I started writing this one
journal entry about my identity because
one of the things that people kept telling me
that were really close to me at the time was that
my sexuality doesn't
define me, but my relationship
my identity comes from Christ
it's something that was
being said to me over and over and over again
and so I just
needed to write certain things down
so one of the things, I kind of only read parts and pieces
of this journal entry that I did
but one of the things I started off with is that
yes, my identity is in Christ
and why my relationship
with God is very important
something else I talked about in my identity
and the same thing is that I'm also Native American
I'm not a white person
and
I have felt
levels of discrimination, I have
felt and experienced
fear from other
people and different things
because of just the color
of my skin
I get around it because
a little bit because I'm
very educated and I can
sound very, I have a certain level of
privilege because of that
but, so I don't go
at all to the same
thing that my African
American family goes through
but
I have experienced that
I know exactly what that means
and what that feels like
and I've never
been scared about my
Christian identity
being Christian, I've never been scared
about me being Native American
ever, but I have been
scared about my, about being gay
so
I wanted to kind of talk to
I want to read this part of my journal entry
so
just like the color of my skin
is different for many people around me
so is my sexuality
I've been attracted to the same sex
however, my sexual desires
don't define me as a person
they just help me understand why
I just happen to feel the same way I do
about the same sex
I am much more than
what my sexuality is
I used to believe that because I
experienced these attractions
you know, it's sinful
it's a part of me
that I have not given over to
the Lord and so therefore
I must be living in the flesh
so I soon
began to measure my own spiritual growth
just based off my same sex attractions
so if I happen to notice a guy
that week or was attracted
to somebody in a movie or
magazine or somewhere
in public or out in church or
at work, then
somehow I was not living my life
according to God's plan for me
and even
when I was dating
girls, I still felt like
I was not good enough
I just was not hitting that bar
of what was expected of me
in my walk with God
so
I would experience a lot of shame and guilt
in my spiritual growth because I just
could never get rid of these
attractions and I would just go through periods of depression
anxiety, I would distance
myself from other people
contemplating
suicide is a part of my
background, alcohol is a part of my background
just other seeking
pleasure seeking behaviors just to
numb the pain and the
disconnect I was feeling around other people
behavior
and orientation
counseling
was introduced to me and that would just
make things sometimes worse
because
it gave me
the tools of what I needed to say
so I could convince the
other people around me that I was changing
when in fact I wasn't
and so I would
say things like, I wasn't born like this
and that homosexuality is a
choice
and so people were being
convinced that I was being free
from my homosexuality when
I was just kind of mimicking and parenting
what I was supposed to say in front of
other people
but
it was one of the things where I had
to
I had to still keep it
a secret. There were times
where I would share this with
other people what was going on in my
life and terrible horrible
things would happen
just personal things
like family
members no longer wanted to be around
children and I was accused
of some horrible things
in relationship to other
children or
just lying and all these
horrible things that
just were not true
and I heard so many times
where Christians would talk about
how
homosexuals are dirty and disgusting
they would start name calling
and all the while
I'm in the room they don't
really know what's going on with me
I would hear about gay people
being beaten up in the news
I would hear people talk about
how gay people need to be rounded up
and shot and killed
and
there's been times I've
experienced physical attacks
because of my perceived
queerness
and so I
I never wanted
to be opened up. I never wanted to be
honest with anybody and talk openly
about this situation with anyone
so I was
more afraid about my
more afraid about my same sex
attractions than I was
about me being
Native American
and even though I've heard that Christians
go through persecution
the same level of persecution I experience
as a Christian is not at all
the same that I did or have
experienced being gay
and so I have to
at the time when I wrote this
I wrote that I have
to lie to other people
I have to be willing to hide this from other people
no one can know the truth about me
and I must keep this a secret
convince them that I am straight
and that's something
again I wrote that in my late 30s
just a few years ago
and
it's crazy
I go back to the story
about the sinful woman
you know
her sins were
very apparent
to the whole entire community
and everything
and Jesus didn't care
Jesus did
not care. The only people that
mattered
was to the Pharisees
to the other people maybe in her life
to the people that she
was just around her
it didn't matter
I don't know if you're familiar with
a children's book
Max Licato wrote a children's book
several years ago it's called
You Are Special
I love this story
I won't go through the whole entire story
or anything like that but I'll kind of go through
the highlights of what this story
is about
but it reminds me
the same thing with the sinful
woman and moral woman as it were
but it's about
this character name
I'm going to say it wrong
so bear with me for those of you who are super
familiar with the story
Pinocchio
it sounds like Pinocchio but it's not exactly that
but the way that this
whole entire works is that these are
little puppets that walk around
society and they go around and they do these
things where if they like what
you do they will give you
a star and if they
don't like what you do they will
go turn around and give you a
black dot
and so they walk around just
giving people
like if you do something amazing
or if they like the way that you look or
you tell a funny joke or there's
a talent that they like they approve of
they give you a star and if there's
something that they don't like
they'll just give you a dot
so they walk around doing this to people
where they just, you know
give them stars or
give them dots
give them stars
or give them dots
for some reason this kind of reminds me of like
I don't know, social media
stars
dots
I've just
sometimes we could do that to each other
we label each
other very quickly with some of the
things that we do
so with this particular main
character
he could never seem to get a star for
anything to save his life
he just couldn't do it
he would try to
do something, he would fail
people would give him dots, he had no
stars on his body at all and of course
as you can imagine
not having anything
on you like that
that other people were validating
he just walked around with a lot of
depression as you can imagine
so eventually
he meets this person
that has nothing
on them
no stars, no dots of any kind
and
the way that the story goes is that
even people would see that
and they would try to put a star on her
it would fall off
they tried putting a dot on her
so nothing would
stick to her
and the main character is like how?
what are you doing?
how is that possible?
and she's like well I've been
meeting with our maker
his name is Eli, he's up at the
woodshed, wood carving place
do you want to go talk to him?
and he's like absolutely
so he goes and he starts
spending time and of course
the story is about spending time with God
it's a mirror
of that but you
go into this of
he spends time talking to
the
to the creator as it were
and it's amazing
I love what he says
to the main character
because the title of the story is that remember
you were special so he says remember
you were special
because I made you
and I don't
make mistakes
I
so needed to hear something like that
somebody tell me that
many years ago
that I'm not
a mistake
I
and I share this with you because
I don't want you to ever walk
around thinking that you're a mistake
it doesn't
matter what
I might think of you, what the person
beside you might think of you, people at work, people
even family members, I know that's kind
of hard to kind of wrap our minds around
but sometimes family members, sometimes
our leaders, whether it's a boss
or it's a co-worker or whether it's something
teachers or whatever it
is that's in your life
like this Pharisee, these are religious leaders
that their center is
just like we are
their opinion of us
doesn't define us
our relationship with God does
so I want to leave you with a couple of
questions
just to kind of ponder and to think about
as you are moving on
and going on into this week
so the first question I want
you to think of is
what is God doing
in your life?
When I first came out
Karen kind of mentioned this, I met up with
Lance Westbrook and one of his
questions he constantly
when we would get together is
he would talk about how is God working in your life
right now? Even in
situations where things are difficult
and things are hard and we
have hard weeks and we have challenging
situations whether it's with family or with
work or finances or
whatever it is with you
what is God
doing in your life?
Where are you?
Where is he using to speak
into you?
And you
are the person that can answer that.
The other
question is that how are you responding
to God's leading
in your life?
For me personally
and like I've already mentioned
journaling for me is super important
to me, it helps me focus
I can get very overwhelmed
easily with all the different
things that are going on sometimes in my life
and it helps me to focus on
what I need to focus on.
I read, of course
I read my bible, I love music
so I spend a lot
of time with praise and worship
songs to help me re-center.
Exercise, something as simple as
just getting out and exercising
something as doing
a hobby
creating something
making a point to connect with another
person that's important
to you. All of these things are
God's
purpose and plan for you
so how
are you responding to that?
And the last thing I want to leave with you
is that how are you helping
yourself and others connect
with God?
I think for me personally
it's so funny when I was growing up
in my early twenties
the meaning of life
for some reason. What is the meaning of life?
was kind of a question that people kept saying
over and over and over again
and I thought it was kind of a funny question
because at least as a Christian
and as a believer, I felt like my meaning
in life was to always
point back to God.
Again, that sounds so churchy
but at the same
time
it kind of still fits.
20 years later
it still kind of fits
and I meet
a lot of different people who
have either been burned by church
burned by family members that are
super religious.
I've met lots of people
that sometimes just don't want to have
anything to do with God
and that can make things a little difficult.
I'm not going to lie
but showing them kindness
showing them love, showing them
mercy and grace
all the things that Jesus
showed this woman
that nobody else would show
is a point of
getting people
back into
mirroring what Christ would have done for us
and hopefully
maybe one day they might listen to
the fact that
they might come visit the table
and meet all of you amazing
people and feel encouraged
and get connected. It would be awesome.
I want to close with this one other
verse
that I just want to
send you off with this little reminder.
It's from Ephesians
2 verse 10.
For we are God's
masterpiece.
He has created us anew
in Christ Jesus so we can do
the good things he's planned for
us long ago.
It helps
me to remember that I have a plan
that God has a plan and I
personally have a purpose and he uses me
for those
purposes. I
think for me right now is
really to connect with other people to help
point them back in some way, shape or form to
God and even if it's just showing
people love, showing
them mercy and compassion in places
where it's really hard to do that
then that's what I need to do.
In the smallest ways
I think as church people we
are really good, really
really good about making meals and
bringing them to people
or just helping people in that
way. That's one of our biggest strengths as a church
community. But
even something as simple as that
speaks volumes for people.
So I want to encourage you
to find that thing
that God is calling you to do and connect
into that. So I'm going to
close this into a word of prayer.
So Lord,
thank you so much
for again this opportunity just
to talk to my table
family. I just
want to encourage
them
even though they may have had a very
challenging week, especially
maybe even the last several months have been very challenging
especially, but
Lord you have a plan and a
purpose for every single one of us.
You know exactly where we are.
You know what we need
and you are so faithful to us.
Help us to remember
that. Help us to lean into that
and then
whenever we can
show that to other people.
In Christ's name I pray. Amen.
From glass alabaster
she poured out the depths
of her soul
O foot of Christ
would you wait
if her heart
were trees known
falls
a tear
to darken
the dirt
of
humblest offering
to forgive the hurt
she is
strong enough to stand
in your love
I can hear her
say
I'm weak
I'm poor
I'm broken
Lord
but I'm yours
hold me
now
let he without
sin
cast the first stone
if he will
to say that my
bride isn't worth
half the blood
that I've spilled
point your finger
and laugh if you choose
to say my beloved
she's borrowed into you
she is strong enough
to stand in my love
I can hear her
say
I'm weak
I'm poor
I'm broken
Lord
but I'm yours
hold me
now
hold me now
I'm weak
I'm poor
I'm broken
Lord
but I'm yours
hold me
now
we're weak
and we're poor
we're broken
Lord
but we're yours
hold us now
hold me
now
thank you so much
for being with us tonight
for being a part of this community
you are
what makes the table
family and home and a community
without you
there is no table
so I just want to remind you
that you are special
because God made you
and he doesn't make mistakes
and if there's any way
we can be there for you
as a church community
please reach out
whether it's practical needs, prayer
or you just need somebody to talk to
please reach out to us at
info at the table
tx.org
we would love to talk with you
and then
we'll keep comments on for just a few more
minutes so you can
just
comment on whatever you like
anything that stuck out to you
or just say hi
reach out to a few people
and I'll leave you
with this benediction
you are a child of God
this is true on your best days
it's true on your
worst days
and it's true during a pandemic
it's also true
for those with whom you vehemently
disagree with about
everything from masks
to politics
to schools opening back up
so as you go into the week ahead
with its yet unknown highs
and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance
that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire
to extend those same gifts
of grace and divine
love to everyone
you come in contact with
especially in online
spaces
be blessed
you are loved and we hope to see you
back here next week. Bye
you